لكنما صعب عده تواجه السيجاره في مصر لذا
وجدت بعض الجمعيات كجمعيه القناص المصري
لرعايه الطيور الجارحه لمساعدته وادي
السفاره في ممارسه هوايتهم بكل يسرا
وسهوله
وهو يد السجاره لم تتوقف عند حد الافراد
الذين يتحركون فرادى دون تنسيق فقد بدات
محاولات الصقارين لجعل الهوايه نشاطا
مؤسسيا يضم المحبين سواء كانوا مبتدئين او
محترفين صغارا او كبارا من البدو او من
غيرهم كان ابرزها جمعيه القناص المصري
التي التقينا عددا من افرادها
جمعيه القناص المصري رعايه الجوارح هي
جمعيه مصريه وانشات 2018
هي تدريب الصقور للصيد بها اييي كان زمان
بيعملوا كده عشان بيوفره احتياجاتهم من
اللحوم في في الاماكن في الصحراويه البدو
كانوا بيدربوا الصغور عشان يستظروهم همم
الطيور في موسم الهجره دلوقتي هي بقت
عباره عن تراث همم
كثير قوي من الدول سواء كانت الدول اوروبا
او دول الخليج بقوا بيهتم جدا بقت اصبحت
الرياضه النهارده همم هي رياضه الصقور او
سباقات الصخور